does Afroman have a secret dungeon newly
obtained body camera footage shows
police raiding the Ohio rapper's home
looking for cannabis and a secret
basement based on a tip from a
confidential informant
anyone else in there
police neither found large amounts of
marijuana nor a secret basement because
confidential informants are notoriously
unreliable Afroman's label says that he
doesn't even have a basement and the
so-called dungeon is actually a crawl
space under the stairs if Afroman is
guilty of anything it's his poor choice
in interior paint color but the real
crime here is police rifling through his
belongings seizing cash that they then
return 400 short and then suing Afroman
when their body camera footage ends up
in his music videos